hallo leute ich es wieder einmal wanne
und ja ihr habt richtig gelesen heute
möchte ich euch die fünf dinge
vorstellen die mich so richtig in
stimmung bringt
aber können wir vorher einmal über
dieses wunderschöne set sprechen ich
habe zwar in die kamera aufgebaut und
dachte - endlich sieht deine wohnung aus
als ob du dein leben im griff hätte es
ist ja nicht so dass hier über die
kartons stimmen die ähnlich sehen könnt
aber kommt das sieht gut aus viele haben
schon gefragt woher diese einpacker bild
ist das werde ich euch nicht verraten
das müsst ihr schon selber herausfinden
außer die firma bezahlt mich dafür dass
ich euch das sage dann ist es wieder
natürlich was ganz anderes und kamen wir
aber zurück zum thema fünf dinge die
mich so richtig in stimmung bringen
in weihnachtsstimmung oh mein gott ich
wusste kannste sich das kann
funktioniert das auch mit
ich kann mir vorstellen eine letzte
sache bin ich noch probieren viele sehr
genervt von der weihnachtszeit oder
wissen nicht ganz genau was sie damit
anfangen sollen aber ich glaube ganz
tief in meinem herzen dass es nur daran
liegt wie man mit dieser ganz besonderen
zeit umgeht und deshalb kommt jetzt
meine ganz klassische tafel ist also let
it snow
das meint dich nicht so nummer 1 in den
ersten tagen räume ich gerne auf und
nicht so wir nehmen den dreck und
schieben ihn woanders hin sondern so
richtig grund legen gut da ich gerade
umgezogen bin kann ich viele dinge
einfach nicht wegräumen besonders diese
ganzen umzugskisten aber mit ein
bisschen damit kann man wirklich alles
passiert und wenn ihr kein lametta zu
hause hat tut es normale weihnachtsdeko
auch nummer zwei stress vermeiden
es ist nämlich nicht nur die
besinnlichste zeit des jahres sondern
auch die stressigste überall gibt es
weihnachtsfeiern man muss geschenke
besorgen es werden noch 100 tests vor
den ferien geschrieben und es wird so
schnell dunkel und warum ist es
plötzlich so arschkalt dass stress doch
heidstock deshalb ist es wichtig rituale
zu haben foto ahlen es können klassische
dinge sein wie meditation oder yoga aber
ich habe da meine ganz eigene methode
ich ziehe mir jeden abend meine
gemütliche weihnachtsmann setze mich auf
meine couch und schaut den neuesten so
eller blog letztes jahr habe ich damit
angefangen und es ist wie eine sucht ich
kann nicht ohne und diese frau schafft
es so schnell dich in weihnachtsstimmung
zu bedenken viele da draußen verstehen
mich lockt mit hersteller ist cool
wisst ihr was noch cool ist essen das
problem dabei ist neben dem
weihnachtsstress hat man natürlich auch
noch diesen arbeitsstress und jetzt als
ich diese day die blogs gemacht habt da
fehlt einfach die motivation und die
zeit zum essen macht da brauchte einfach
kleine helfer und snacks wie dieses
porridge khujo nur von erman wer
porridge nicht kennt das ist ein ganz
beliebter frühstückspreis glaube er
kommt aus england auf jeden fall machst
du haferflocken mit wasser und milch
zusammen du kochst das und dann hast du
halt diesen brei oder du machst so wie
hier
ganz einfach nur den deckel auf links
vielleicht ein paar heidelbeeren drauf
und schon was für ein leckeres frühstück
das dich lange satt hält viele proteine
hat und super schnell geht
ehrmann keiner macht mich mehr an und
wenn wir schon mal beim essen sind
kochen ist ein super ritual für den
abend wenn ihr nach einem langen tag
nach hause kommt und ich um etwas
schönes zubereitet ja es frisst zeit ich
weiß manchmal hat man auch einfach keine
lust vielleicht kann man sich ja noch
eine serie nebenbei an machen und dann
einfach was richtig schön ist ist dann
ist das gut für die seele und schnappt
euch einfach einen becher queue ehrmann
keiner macht mich wer an nummer drei
weihnachtskarten schreiben eigentlich
sollte man sich immer bei seiner familie
melden aber im alltag ist es dann doch
ein bisschen schwierig zur
weihnachtszeit sollte man sich aber
wirklich die zeit nehmen und die familie
und die besonderen menschen in deinem
leben die musst du halt einfach mal ein
bisschen depreciation und sagen schön
dass es dich gibt weil man kommt ja
sonst dazu nicht wann kommst du denn mal
im alltag dazu zu sagen wo die super
wetter muttertag oder in ihrem
geburtstag oder an ihrem namenstag aber
zum beispiel bei deiner besten freundin
geburtstag und soja klar natürlich war
so eine weihnachtskarte ist einfach
schön ich finde es auch toll sich
hinzusetzen und sich irgend etwas
schönes zu überlegen was man dieser
person schreiben kann also ich freue
mich jedes mal einen runden keks und ich
weiß alle ecken ab weil die post nicht
nur aus rechnung besteht erwachsensein
machen spaß nummer vier du musst dir
etwas gutes tue ja das klingt wie ein
katzen poster spruch und von selbst
lieber haben wir alles schon gehört aber
zur selbst liebe gehört nicht nur dazu
dass du dich ganz in ordnung findest
sondern dass du dir auch wirklich mal
was gutes tue sie leben nämlich in einer
gesellschaft in der bett das leisten
müssen um eine belohnung zu bekommen ich
sage dazu quatsch mit soße und wenn du
den ganzen tag auf der couch verbracht
das unten vl stück bist und du kannst du
ja trotzdem was gutes tun und ich
biologie renner sagt dass ihr immer so
schön man soll sein eigener bester
freund sein und ich erwarte von meinen
besten freunden nicht nur dass sie mir
was gutes tun wenn ich geburtstag habe
oder so oder wenn ich was geleistet habe
ich möchte bitte immer liebe bekommen
ich bin es wert geliebt zu werden
und du
du und du und du auch und ganz besonders
gehe zu einem schönen konzert kauft die
eine überteuerte badekugeln und legt
sich mit guter musik in die badewanne
oder kräftig mit deinen freunden und
macht einen gemeinsamen kochabend die
dunkle jahreszeit muss auch wenn uns den
spaß zu verderben wir können auch
richtig lustige sachen drin und im
warmen macht nummer fünf es klingt jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen blöd aber ich
muss mindestens einmal im jahr auf den
weihnachtsmarkt irgendwie ruft mein
inneres kind immer noch so stark nach
gebrannten mandeln einem apfel mit
zuckerglasur und glühwein dass ich es
nur befriedigen kann indem ich mich vor
diese überfüllten ständigen stelle und
überteuertes zeug kaufen was eh nicht so
gut für mich ist aber wenn ich etwas
glücklich macht dann kannst du auch mal
kurz die vernunft ausschalten und dinge
tun die einfach nur spaß machen und wenn
das alles nichts für euch ist dann
schaut euch ein weihnachtsfilm an da
kommt ihr sofort und stimmungen oder ihr
es den quark ich cremigen porridge
genuss kurmann keiner macht mich mehr an
und ich würde sagen wir sehen uns dann
wieder beim nächsten video dank kehrmann
für die unterstützung und wenn euch das
video gefallen habt dann einmal daumen
nach oben das würde mich sehr freuen
eure tipps für die weihnachtsstimmung in
die kommentare
hier sind noch zwei weitere videos dort
könnt ihr mich abonnieren
pressebox yes no kommen
bis dann es ist leichter geworden das
video